a good afternoon and welcome to the
American Enterprise Institute I'm very
pleased to see all of you here for an
AEI book forum today and just in case
you haven't already seen your copy let
me hold it up the book is titled global
financial warriors the untold story of
International Finance in the post 9/11
world the author of the book is seated
to my immediate right this is Professor
John Taylor he will be leading off the
remarks today let me just give you a bit
of a background on Professor Taylor and
I won't do full justice to his is bio
you can find a lengthier version in your
packet and then I'll also give you some
background on the two speakers who will
follow mr. Taylor so John Tanner is a
professor of economics at Stanford
University and a senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford he has
held a number of positions inside and
outside of the government in recent
years
these include he is currently a member
of the Governor's Council of Economic
Advisors in the state of California he
was formerly a member of the President's
Council of Economic Advisers in in DC
his book is essentially a chronicle of
many of his experiences in the issues
and that he dealt with during his time
as Under Secretary of Treasury for
international affairs from 2001 to 2005
and if you spoke in John or if you read
his book you'll know he had the the
fortune or misfortune to take this
position shortly before 9/11 so he was
certainly put into the thick of things
with some immediacy and urgency I will
let I will let John talk about some of
the events that he chronicles in his
book and after after we hear from
Professor Taylor we've got two speakers
unfortunately Paul Wolfowitz who was on
the program
was unable to attend today due to a
death in the family and I'm very pleased
to say though that Alastair McKechnie at
the World Bank has agreed to fill in on
very short notice he is the World Bank's
country director for Afghanistan
Afghanistan Bhutan Maldives and the
regional programs he has extensive
experience at the World Bank in South
Asia the Middle East and North Africa I
think he is intimately familiar with
much of the material that's discussed in
professor
Taylor's book and he is well positioned
to give us a different perspective on
some of the same events the professor
Taylor will describe following up will
be far years odd he is at Goldman Sachs
& Company since August 2006 where he is
vice president and director of
international public policy he is
responsible for coordinating the firm's
efforts with respect to international
public policy matters as well as
advising clients on related matters he
also has extensive first-hand knowledge
of the events that are recounted in mr.
Taylor's book he was formerly on the
staff until quite recently of the
National Security Council to the White
House from March 2003 to just prior to
the position he took up at Goldman Sachs
he served there as a special assistant
to the president for international
economic affairs and then as deputy
assistant to the president and deputy
national security advisor for
International Economic Affairs so we've
lined up an excellent panel here and
please welcome please join me in
welcoming our first speaker professor
Taylor
[Applause]
thank you very much for organizing this
and for inviting me to speak about my
new book and I really so pleased to have
two experts on join me on the panel that
I work with many many days and months
and years when I was on the job in both
Afghanistan with Alistair and the White
House with far you are so it is too
privileged to be on the panel with you I
want to start off my discussion of the
book with a little personal story it's a
story about a meeting that took place in
the Oval Office in the fall of 2003 so
it was about halfway through the period
that I was the Under Secretary of
Treasury for international affairs
heading up the international division
it's a story about both leadership and
public service it's a personal story too
because the president wanted to show my
immediate family around the Oval Office
so there we were my wife who actually
Lynn who happens to be right in front of
me right now so she can attest that what
I'm telling my my daughter and my son
and as we talked about the various
things in the Oval Office a particular
conversation began between my the
president and my son who happened to be
wearing his Marine uniform at the time
having just finished OCS in Quantico as
in just commissioned as a second
lieutenant so president said just
graduated from OCS from college how many
other graduates in your class from
college join the Marines
well none sir but there'll be some
others and some other classes coming up
I'm sure really appreciate your service
for the country the president said on
the president want to say that you know
we have a very powerful country we have
to defend ourselves people depend on us
that's why we need the Marines right sir
so my son somewhat
I'm back that the commander-in-chief of
the entire US Armed Forces was calling a
second weekend and sir went back to him
very fast yes sir so I tell that story
because what the president said about
the Marines we need them seems to me and
this is what I'd like to suggest in this
book seems to me can be applied to a
whole different type of expert if you
like whole different mission the
financial experts and that's why I've
titled this book global financial
warriors because we need these financial
experts in this new world it's because
the United States is a powerful economic
financial country it's because this war
on terror that we're in now we're going
to be in for a while it's because the
financial aspects of this war are so
important so that's why I'd like to
bring attention to that whole idea in
this book who are these global financial
warriors anyway
well a lot of them work in the US
Treasury that 350 or so people who work
for me when I was undersecretary or who
are continuing to work there now not
only in the main Treasury Building a few
blocks from here but also at the
international financial institutions and
not only the IMF on the World Bank but
also representing the United States and
the other international financial
institutions around the world but in
addition they're the experts from the US
Treasury who are advising
Phidias ministries in economic and
central bank's in roughly now about 70
different countries around the world
giving giving expertise as they set up
central banks or design the budgets and
Finance Ministry's there's a for the
frontispiece for my book not too many
books have frontispiece as these days I
thought I'd put a frontispiece in and
for my frontispiece by the way of those
who've you forgot the frontispiece is
the part that comes right here near the
front but the frontispiece that's a
poster is a poster of Uncle Sam pointing
at you and it says we're at war
are you doing all you can and is that
poster that for many months sat in the
main entrance north entrance to the
Treasury where the some of the global
financial warriors were going by so they
include people like David NUMMI who went
to Baghdad
a week's days after actually Saddam
Hussein fell to start to set up a
central bank and a finance ministry it
includes people like Larry Steele who
did the same thing in Afghanistan later
on later on went to Liberia after
Charles Taylor the tyrant no relation of
course was torn out of Liberia
and he set up the first budget for the
Afghan government on his laptop computer
just an amazing activity but it's not
only people working for the Treasury or
the United States government it's more
broadly speaking so for example another
another is Ashraf Ghani is the first
finance minister of Afghanistan in the
Karzai government I call him in my book
the Alexander Hamilton of his country
because he had a job but unlike
Alexander Hamilton he had to bring in
these unruly governors are called
warlords I don't think Alexander
Hamilton to deal with warlords necessary
but unruly governors is very much
similar ringing so they've contributed
their customs revenues to the central
government he also had to set up a
finance ministry just like I was there
Hamilton set one up so these are some of
the people that I really want to praise
so much in this book now in many
respects this financial warrior activity
these financial experts doing so many
things have become more important since
9/11 in fact the subtitle of my book as
Steve indicated is called the untold
story of international finance in the
post 9/11 world so the book actually
starts on 9/11 I was in Japan on 9/11
starting to do what people my job
normally do negotiate with the Japanese
on a on some financial issues we had to
fly back right away actually as I see
Mike Phelps from The Wall Street Journal
over there in the audience he was at the
same place the same time
in Japan at that point a good good
recollection of what happened that day
but I had to fly back to the United
States on a military transport c-17 the
only way to get back I remember so
vividly we had to have an early
refueling over Alaska to get back fast I
don't know how many of you done an arrow
you're fueling in a c-17 from a tanker
there you are flying 500 miles an hour
in the dark of night and your distance
between you and the tanker is about that
far and the hose comes down you can see
the guys in the plane above just an
amazing display of raw nerve and amazing
technical skills to me that would many
respects was a watershed if you like
because my world changed completely when
I got back to Washington after that trip
suddenly we were asked to combat
terrorist financing what does that mean
freeze terrorists assets freeze
al-qaeda's assets form an international
coalition to help in that freezing of
the assets the epigram epigraph from my
book which is right next to the
frontispiece is what President Bush said
on September 24 2001 when we started
this chase after the terrorists assets
I'll read it because it's the theme of
the book this war on terrorism will be
fought on a variety of fronts the
president said these front lines will
look different from wars of the past it
is a war that will require the United
States to use our influence in a variety
of areas in order to win it in one area
is financial so that is the theme of the
book and it begins with chapter 1 called
the first shot in the war on terror was
when this action was taken on September
24th even before the Allied troops went
into Afghanistan and it continues right
through to the epilogue which tries to
draw conclusions from the many stories
like that in the book to try to
summarize what in the what's here rather
than do chapter by chapter I always want
to mention five points or themes that I
think I think of when I want to talk
about the book first name I call it the
high marks theme
it turns out and this is going to be a
surprise to most readers perhaps the
mother of all surprises I don't know
there's a lot of positive stories in
this books a lot of it's a story by
things that actually worked pretty well
and it's documented well I think about
why they worked well it's not just that
they worked well there's the details of
why they worked well the disrupting of
the financing of terrorists is part of
it but also there was early on a amazing
end if you like to the global financial
contagion which was such a concern
around 9/11 as Argentina Turkey were in
deep financial trouble but there was
also important efforts to have reform at
the World Bank moving from loans to
grants measurable result system and
ultimately a hundred percent
cancellation of the poor country's debt
at the World Bank so so these are what I
would call one success story after
another if you like I think readers
actually people who I've talked to
already have been amazed by certain
parts of the book for example the effort
to provide for financial stability in
Iraq after Saddam fell for this we
decided we need a whole new currency in
the country so it's a story about
printing enough currency to fill 27 747
planeloads sliding into Baghdad having
been printed at seven different printing
plants around the world and in record
time and then after all that
distributing the 250 distribution points
around the country that was the plan
hard enough to imagine that as a plan
but the tough thing to imagine is it
worked and actually actually took place
so that's very closely documented we
hear so much about what's gone wrong and
so many books have been wooden about
what's gone wrong this is a different
tack this is about what went right it's
good to hear about what went right -
especially if you can learn about it so
you should ask why things went right and
I try to do that in the book and try to
come up with some conclusions that was
my first point high marks and by the way
the marks is used because it's not just
me saying this obviously you'd be
suspicious if it was just me
it's not just me saying this for example
the 9/11 Commission in their report card
on the war on terror they were tough
graders they gave out failing grades
they give out these they gave out C's
they only gave one grade in the a
category a range we call it as a
professor as my professor area work it
was an a-minus and that was to what's
discussed in this book in particular the
combating of the terrorist financing so
there's a lot here to learn about in the
positive way second this book in many
respects questions conventional wisdom
you have to read it to be convinced but
just as a summary one conventional
wisdom is there really hasn't been much
diplomacy in the United States and
recent years or diplomacy has failed
well in the cases of financial diplomacy
that I report on in this book that's not
true it's not a good characterization so
for example in the right after 9/11
financial diplomacy was used to get a
coalition of countries to agree to
freeze the assets of the terrorists 172
countries participated in that freezing
at the time so unprecedented I always
would say it's the best example best
case of international cooperation since
the Bretton Woods institutions were
founded towards the end of World War two
and I think it's really true and now
others say the same thing but in
addition right after this period five
billion dollars was raised just
immediately - for post-war construction
in Afghanistan and Amin in Tokyo in
January 2002 the agreement to reduce the
poor country's debt by a hundred percent
required an immense agreement and
diplomacy around the world to make that
happen so I could go on and on but if
anything if you look here and look at
the details I want to provide stories
for the details you'll find success on
the financial side another other by the
way another example by the way of
conventional wisdom is there were there
was no advance planning for a post so
on Iraq well read the chapters in the
book about planning or financial
stability in Iraq and you'll see with
maybe too much detail if you like about
what we were doing to have a plan to
provide for financial stability and
that's where the president is involved
myself is involved our interagency
process is involved other countries our
allies in particularly the British the
Australians and the Spanish involved and
you'll see a surprising amount of
advanced planning so again in the areas
where I can report about from my vantage
point you'll see a different story than
what is conventional wisdom the Third
Point has to do with this rather unusual
vantage point I have had for writing
this book the privilege if you like I
had to have this vantage point my
publisher calls it a unique vantage
point or unmatched vantage point well it
certainly was unusual yes I was involved
in meetings at the NSC with the
president where decisions were made yes
I was at the g7 finance ministers
meetings where the decisions were made
say on a rock debt or 100 percent debt
cancellation but more important than
that it seems to me I was also on the
ground where the decisions were being
carried out and so not only did I
participate in over 400 meetings in the
White House obviously can't remember all
those but I also went to make 120 visits
to foreign countries including many to
Iraq many to invest
of Afghanistan and many to Africa and I
say that not just to boast but simply to
say this is a vantage point which is
rather unusual to both be at the top and
see that and to see how its implemented
at the ground level and I try to share
that experience if you like with others
who want to read the book in the book
and I'd like to just read one example of
that maybe a couple of examples about
reporting from Afghanistan for elections
Alistair is here who has had long
experience in the country but this is a
story about going to the westernmost
province of Afghanistan right next to
the Iranian border
to try to convince the then warlord
Ishmael Khan to provide more funds to
the center of the government in other
words helping the finance minister to
rein in some of the unruly governor's
his name the warlord was named Ishmael
Khan so I went to arrive by plane landed
on at the airport and I'll quote we were
greeted on the tarmac by a long line of
officials they were all men mostly older
or middle-aged with full beards son worn
leathery skin each one was eager to
shake hands and welcome us American
soldiers and State Department security
forces carrying m16s were there to guard
us scanning the tarmac and beyond for
possible terrorists or disgruntled
former Taliban a contingent of Ishmael
Khan's militia was also there armed with
their own ak-47 automatic rifles it
occurred to me that our guys may have
been protecting us from his guys but the
truth is the American military and the
errata militia were working together at
that time and had been for months after
coming to the end of the long line of
official handshakes I was greeted warmly
by Ishmael Kong who asked me to ride
with him back to his house in town in
his SUV so we could begin our talks or
negotiations informally Khan wore a
traditional Afghan turban distinctive
Niel ain't white overcoat over a flowing
white robe with a large white beard he
had been a Musha Dean commander had
fought both the Soviets and the Taliban
as I sat with Khan in the SUV and
started talking with him I thought how
different this scene was from the kind
of financial diplomacy that I had
imagined I'd be doing when I joined the
Treasury before 9/11 this was no plush
negotiating room with high ceilings
you'd sandal ears stuffed chairs and
long tables like those in the corridors
of Finance in the Western world instead
I looked out over the dashboard of
Khan's SUV and I saw the mushiya Dean in
the pickup truck ahead so it seems to me
there's some value to discussing this is
actually how it's done you do these
things this is when people ask me what I
do
in Washington license why some other
things I did elsewhere but this is what
I did the fourth point of my five is
these are I think a lot of inspirational
stories in many respects about about
what people who do public service and
difficult circumstances go through and
actually one read one more thing to
illustrate that aspect of it the person
who was eventually assigned to be the
point person in Iraq on the currency
exchange which I mentioned was a former
Brigadier General who had been running
the bank in and the south and he says
this and is this is the acknowledgement
section of my book he says this about
the book and about his role memories are
still overwhelmingly powerful thank you
for writing this important story and for
complete for including our team's
efforts as part of it I retired from the
military on October 1st 2001 after
saying goodbye to people I had worked
closely with for five-and-a-half years
at the Pentagon 33 of these budget
personnel who regularly got me smart to
go and brief the hill perished on 9/11
as well as two of my close friends I'd
been a banker with South Coast community
bank for only four months when I
received the call to serve as a director
of the currency exchanges a person who
volunteered and was in many ways
responsible for the success he and
people like him who were dedicated to
this job fifth point is I think in many
respects this is a timely time to
consider these issues president of
course is speaking tomorrow night about
a new way forward the new leadership in
Congress wants to implement the 9/11
Commission recommendations
so there's let and there are lessons
learned from this I think with respect
to the 9/11 Commission recommendations
please don't take any emphasis away from
this successful part of it the combating
terror is financing if anything give
more emphasis to that there's there's
real opportunities here now in the
proliferation area to use these weapons
with respect to Iran and North Korea so
more emphases more support more praise
if you like with this operation it
should be non partisan is no reason to
be partisan about this and then finally
more generally about lessons learned I
tried to in the end and the epilogue go
through and ask why did things work in
the way they did and I think there's two
basic things and they're both obvious
when you say them but they just just
jump out at you one is in every success
that I write about there was a very
clear mission financial stability in
Iraq international coalition to combat
terrorism ancing very clear mission of
what you had to do plus there was a team
of people put together to carry out that
mission mission and team of the two
things the teams themselves seems to me
had four characteristics that I would
recommend as much as possible in
government operations four
characteristics is obviously skilled
people who knew what they were doing
number two a sense people who had a
sense of the mission I just someone told
the mission but they internalized had a
sense of that mission number three
autonomy enough autonomy to do the job
perhaps in this area because it's more
arcane in other areas it did it was not
a lot of interagency interference if you
like it was not a lot of constraints on
things so autonomy was given to the
experts who knew what to do and rarely
although of course sometimes questioned
and then the fourth thing quite related
to the autonomy his accountability very
clear timelines benchmarks of getting
things done requirements to report back
to me whoever was in charge of the time
and so those four things skilled sense
of the mission autonomy and
accountability seem to me is what made
these teams do what they did thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you John Callister thank you very
much I would also like to apologize
again on behalf of Paul Wolfowitz who is
unable to come here today and he spoke
with me this morning a couple of times
and I know how very much he would have
liked to have been here so I'd like to
convey his apologies
and because of time and more truthfully
do to my limited personal knowledge of
all the areas covered in the book I'm
going to confine my comments to
Afghanistan and and the World Bank I
very much enjoyed reading this personal
account of the first two years of
rebuilding Afghanistan and it really
discusses the issue faced by those of us
tasked with rebuilding Afghanistan at
that time it also contains some
interesting anecdotes and observations
on the diverse cast of characters
involved in this work and since I have
been a slave to video conferences and
had an early education and electrical
engineering and worked among diplomats I
particularly enjoyed the story of
ambassador Sal Khalil's adds confusion
over his mute button and two shirt
buttons during a video conference with
President Bush but for those of us
working on Afghanistan at that time John
Taylor's account has a ring of authority
it reminds us of a time of crisis
uncertainty opportunity and great hope
for the Afghan people as he tells us in
his book this was a time when many
countries international organizations
and US government agencies had to
organize themselves to deliver quick
results that the Afghan people were
expecting and to do this at a time when
the Afghan interim administration was
still finding its feet valuable time
would have been lost if the US
government had not taken the lead in
organizing the first meetings of
Afghanistan's partners since in the
absence of legitimate government there
was really no other party willing or
able to take the first step
yet as John Taylor tells us as Afghan
institutions began to assert themselves
particularly a navy led finance ministry
under Ashraf Ghani and central bank
under Anwar al haq Hadi the u.s. stood
back to empower them and provided strong
leadership and support from behind the
scenes
John Taylor also relates how the usual
problems of interagency coordination
within the US government were resolved
much of the success in mobilizing
international resources for Afghanistan
was due to good teamwork between John
and his counterparts Elle Larson at
state Dov Zakheim at Pentagon and Czar
Khalilzad at NSC never lists the fact
that the President himself needed to
keep up the pressure to complete a major
road project on time shows how difficult
it is to overcome bureaucratic inertia
and John's book tells that inertia is
not unique to the United States other
organizations required similar prodding
into action for results John is not
modest about his impact on mobilizing
financial resources for Afghanistan
I remember how his personal involvement
avoided the government the Afghan
government from not meeting its payroll
in 2002 the book tells of simultaneous
audio conferences with large numbers of
countries to raise funds and his realism
and in encouraging support to be pulled
through the Afghanistan reconstruction
trust fund this fund has greatly
simplified 'add support promoted
transparency and accountability even
though the political pressure within the
donor countries was for bilateral
assistance that avoided budget support
as John mentioned assistance from his
Treasury advisors in the Afghan Ministry
of Finance were critical for ensuring
that Afghanistan adopted good budget
practices accountability for resources
and
economic stability and this was done in
an environment where none of this was a
foregone conclusion and not only did he
have to shake the donors the chapter
graphically describes the efforts and he
read from this section of having to go
to her out with finance minister to
ensure that customs revenues were
transferred to Kabul and I particularly
liked the SEC surf and I'm glad that you
that you read it and I think this is one
of several adventures of this global
financial warrior that the Volk tells
about that few senior Treasury officials
have experienced since America's own
post-conflict period in the late 18th
century if while the book is
entertaining it also leads us to learn
from the Afghan experience so that we
can all do better next time
when we have to respond to a country
emerging from crisis such as Liberia we
were successful in raising substantial
money substantial money for Afghanistan
but this raised Afghan expectations that
that were difficult to fill as Ismail
Khan tells John Taylor they have heard
that billions of dollars have been
raised to help Afghanistan but they can
see so little of it being used in their
areas even a bureaucratic sloth can be
eliminated it still takes time to build
things accelerating investment too much
then costs go up and the effectiveness
of assistance is questioned by the
recipients and the taxpayers bypassing
weak government systems in the interests
of speed can weaken local ownership and
capacity and create a dependency indeed
in poor countries like Afghanistan
emerging from decades of conflict the
challenge challenge is not
reconstruction as in post-world War two
Europe and Japan where human capacity
and institutions existed that rebuilding
the state itself not fixing broken
assets
since few existed before the
conflict but building institutions as
John describes not simple clean
construction but the whole messy
business of development I would now like
to turn to John Taylor's account of
reforming the World Bank and as one of
the staff working there at the time I
thanked him for a statement that the
reforms were directed at the institution
and not those working in it nevertheless
we fully agree with John that what gets
measured gets done especially when
financed the services we finance do not
face market tests better results
management is now one of the bank's
priorities indeed measuring outputs and
impacts of our finances and advice is in
retrospect so glaringly obvious that
Paul Wolfowitz has asked why it took 60
years to get it done
results results measurement is now
mainstreamed and indeed this morning I
chaired a meeting to review a grant for
a rural road program in Afghanistan with
a star preparing the project presented
very clearly the results they expected
measuring output such as the number of
textbooks financed is fairly
straightforward measuring impacts though
what children actually learn in school
and how this benefits them is more
difficult
John Taylor rightly claims credit for
pushing the results agenda I also felt
his influence in the design of
reconstruction after the Asian tsunami
but all of us involved in development
still have a lot to do to better measure
the impact of our interventions John
also describes the major role he played
in getting debt relief endorsed by the
leaders of the g8 he describes the
debates on how to provide meeting
meaningful relief to borrowers while
preserving Ida that's our soft loan
affiliates financial strength at the
same time debt relief has to be
sustainable so that it does not lead to
permanent reductions
so sorry so that it does lead to
permanent reductions in poverty and not
renewed debt problems it is worth
mentioning that debt relief without the
opening of markets is a partial policy
that will not help developing countries
escape their poverty debt relief has to
be combined with fairer rules for trade
and additional support for meritorious
development efforts these are the
commitment a fully financed Ida were the
pillars of the Byrne Eagle summit and we
still have a long way to go on several
of these fronts a successful Doha round
and delivery of the promised increase in
aid to Africa in particular would be
most helpful and I would note that there
has been significant performance in a
third of the countries in Africa the
other great issue where John Taylor
played a major role was in the debate
over loans versus grants from an Ida
perspective loans were key to the
functioning of IDA as a credit union
whereby reimbursements of IDA credits
provide the basis for other loans to
deserving country countries based on
their institutional and policy
performance a good balance in our view
must be found in the loans versus grants
debate especially now that debt relief
is being implemented debt relief and the
shift towards grants rather than loans
but Hooves all providers of credit
official as well as private to heed the
principles of Responsible Lending
without this discipline we may face
renewed debt burg burdens that are
simply unsustainable let me thank you
for this invitation to be here and for
the opportunity to read this fascinating
account of the dismal science and action
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much Alex
fire thanks Steve I appreciate the
opportunity to be here to be a part of
John getting the chance to unveil the
book that he has written on his time in
Treasury I had the privilege of working
very closely with John on most of the
issues that he describes in the book so
I can vouch for the authenticity of the
stories the details I think it's a
particularly important book because it
talks about an agenda that frankly
doesn't get as much attention as it
probably should I move the exception of
good reporters like Mike Phillips and
others it's a beat that is often
overshadowed and I think for a lot of
understandable reasons by the broader
sort of core foreign policy and national
security agenda and I think that sort of
overlooking of the international
economic agenda obscures the fact that
the integration between the foreign
policy and national security agendas and
the economic agenda is one that's taken
place very much very much whether people
like it or not or whether people realize
it or not it's a new world that we're
living in and I think John tells the
story of that integration and the
emergence of international finance as a
core part of the International national
international diplomacy and
international security agenda very well
I think what John's book does very well
too is it tells the story with all the
texture from with with of the personal
recollections of somebody that was
actually in the front lines living the
agenda and I think that's important for
a number of reasons one is because it
makes for a much more interesting book
to talk about some of the personal
anecdotes that John shares but it's also
important because the personal anecdotes
are telling about the challenges that
are really part and parcel of effective
policymaking as John said and says in
the book and he said here a minute ago
ultimately the issue of effective
policymaking isn't simply a challenge of
coming up with clever ideas I think I
think there's a lot of people who can
come up with with great ideas the
challenge comes in understanding how to
operationalize and implement and measure
and sustained effort when an idea
ultimately is brought to fruition and
and made a reality and that requires a
lot of work it requires a lot of
management requires a lot of skills that
that sometimes may not come naturally to
each of us who come into government but
it's something that I think we all
recognize is part and parcel of being
able to leave a policy legacy that will
endure beyond beyond our own short 10
yrs in government be a personal texture
that John had in this book is actually
interesting for me because some of the
things that he described in there are
things that I actually lived through
from not just from a policy and
professional perspective but also from a
personal perspective there's one of the
first stories he talks about is from his
time I think it might be the first NSC
meeting you describe where you were in
their briefing the president about the
euro currency strategy John you may not
remember this was actually my first NSC
meeting as well and people don't know
that for these NSC meetings it's very
much as John describes which I think is
one of the enjoyable parts of the book
he talks about how the other meeting
participants show up then the president
comes in he gets coffee from a little
table that sits on the side of the
Situation Room then he sits down the
meeting begins the part he didn't talk
about though is that typically when
there's multiple issues on the agenda
people are shuttled in and out and
there's assigned seats and somebody's
supposed to get out and the next person
comes in and takes the seed and so when
we got when the NSC meeting to turn to
the currency part of the agenda that was
actually the part where one colleague
who will remain unnamed was supposed to
step out and I was supposed to step in
and I remember walking into that meeting
realizing that my colleague had not
stepped in and being the only standing
person in a very very small room where
there's really no standing room other
than obstructing the president's path to
his coffee which which I discovered was
not the place to be when he looked at me
and kind of asked me how I was doing
which was which was code for it you
shouldn't be standing there and actually
if I could continue the story when what
John describes is sitting in the back
row with his knee essentially almost of
the abutting the chair in front of him
but he may not have paid attention as he
stood up to present his currency
strategy condi actually motioned to me
to go and take your seat while you were
and John having been in that room you
know there wasn't bunch of room there
between the seat in front you and and
the seat that you just stood up from and
so but I think these are all parts that
story his story of his going to Iraq and
not being met by the delegation that was
supposed to meet them and a number of
other things in there I think are useful
because they not as I said before not
only make the book interesting but I
think they're important to understand
there's a very human dimension to
policymaking that makes that makes
governance interesting but it also
presents you know highlight some of the
challenges there's a couple of broader
takeaways I had from the book that I
think were reflective of the kind of
takeaways that I had from my own
experience in government and I think
there are things that John talks about
he talked about him here and he talked
about them in the book itself but I
think they're worth underscoring the
first is the most obvious point which is
I think is the premise of the book and
that is that the national security
agenda and the economic agenda are now
fully integrated and I think it's a
matter frankly for people to understand
that that's the reality of how
governance works how how policy works
these days and I think in a lot of ways
the Bush administration was successful
in anticipating some of that and I think
some of it was reflected in structural
changes in government for example the
Treasury secretary and having a seat at
the NSC the creation of the position
that I used to occupy as the deputy
national security advisor for
International Economics whose job it was
to be the point person with it within
the White House sitting in the NSC
coordinating all international economic
issues which in previous administrations
were more spread out functionally
through different offices in the White
House and even in the NSC itself we
actually did something that was also in
some respect reflected in the State
Department that was to integrate
economic staff in the regional offices
so each of the regional offices at the
NSC but also in the regional bureaus at
state you had very much a recognition
that without the economics getting being
done right the foreign policy wouldn't
be done right and I think the time that
John describes as a time
that that that reality I think is set in
for everyone the second related point is
takeaway I had was the importance of
collaboration I think sometimes when
people and I know I saw this when I was
at the White House people who sometimes
talk about speculated about whether this
agency or that agency was diminished
whether Treasury was somehow taking us
backseat to the White House I think what
that criticism often misunderstood is
that because of the integration of the
economics and the foreign policy that it
was natural that there be an emergence
of additional players on what was
traditionally seen as the international
economic stage it's impossible to do
international economics without
recognizing whether it's Iraq and
Afghanistan that state has to be there
and defense has to be there whatever the
agenda item happens to be even on the
currency issues where John talks about
the NSA's involvement and sort of
recognizes the role that some of us they
are played and in helping in that in
that front that these are there's no
sort of exclusive policy sandbox left I
think in Washington and I think the
measure of power and success in
Washington is no longer whether an
agency's effective in boxing out
colleagues from a particular policy area
but the effectiveness of a particular
agency and a policymaker and bringing in
collaboration collaborators from the
other agencies to work effectively
together to get a policy implemented and
I think John in the way that he talks
about the role the state and other
agencies played in helping with
different parts of the work he was doing
I think is as a model for how that can
be done well and I think he deserves a
lot of credit for them I think the third
takeaway I had was the importance of
ideas you know as long if you get the
process right ultimately it doesn't mean
anything without a core kind of set of
principles and vision to guide what we
all do you know as people say if you
don't know where you're going any path
will get you there and I think John and
I benefited from a president who gave us
a set of clear vision when we had a
particular challenge that we were trying
to face and in some respects there was
some tension that's created between
having a clear vision of where you want
to go and then doing all the things I
just
described about collaboration and
cooperation and I think that's the job
of folks like the the NSC and others to
make sure you get the collaboration
right so that the vision is not obscured
in the hook in the practical operational
decisions that have to be made as a part
of figuring out how to implement a
particular policy and the fourth
takeaway I had was really a credit to
John you know John and I spent many many
many hours working together on a number
of issues and I think sort of his
experience his expertise skill and his
sort of decency as a person I think is
is very comes through in the book and
and so it wasn't very much of a
privilege to serve with you John and
also to help you unveil your book so I'm
glad to be here thank you thank you very
much for party are would you like to
respond briefly John or would you like
to go directly to Q&A
very quickly just I appreciate so much
remarks in many respects I think this is
many respect this kind of dialogue is
what I think we need more of to
understand this period oh one of the
people who encouraged me to do this book
was my good friend and colleague is
George Shultz who I dedicated the book
to by the way the books dedicated to
George Shultz and in sort of giving him
reasons not to do it sees it's too close
so it'll just be my view he said well no
you should get your view out because
there'll be plenty of other people who
can come and give the other perspectives
if you like the far you are telling me
what his view of me giving the briefing
to the president was and I didn't see
condi out the side of my eyes but that
kind of is a different view in the
literal sense but what I mean is
different of you in the in the sense of
this is one person's view and you in
history really it's part of history but
history will require many other views as
well but the thing that you mentioned
about is all I don't know if people
understood what that was but it was
quite an interesting little episode and
I'm sure I can find it quickly
here to mention it but it really it was
a meeting in the Situation Room and moon
read and zall was on the video secure
video from Kabul and the rest of us were
in the Situation Room and Zhou was
getting we're getting a briefing from
Pete pace actually and so the first we
discussed the we discussed the budget
myself and John Snow and and then we
here's the story while we discussed the
budget myself in Washington's all had
pressed the mute button on his speaker
controls in Kabul when it was his turn
to speak he forgot to press the mute
release and we could only see his mouth
moving without any sound president Bush
told him to press the speaker button but
apparently all Zhou heard was the word
button so he quickly looked on at his
shirt like a shoppin s character in a
silent movie in the whole sit room broke
into uncontrollable laughter until it
dawned on Zhou what the problem was he
pressed the speaker button was heard in
Washington and went on to report how the
new constitutional Loya Jirga was going
and his efforts to bring the different
parties together so one of those moments
of levity that keeps us all sane thanks
John just before I go to Q&A I want to
mention that there are copies of the
book available outside in case you
didn't notice on your way in
so let's go to QA we've got a large
audience here I'm sure they're many
questions so try to be to the point and
before you pose your question please
identify yourself by stating your name
and organization Mahmoud Kumar from a
you I just finished my PhD a few weeks
ago and my research focus has been on
these very issues homeland security and
the financing apparent I just had three
questions and you know Farrar and John
can both step and if you like
firstly there's been a shift in in
terrorist financing control from asset
freezes to financial intelligence how
far has that worked actually because
acid freezers were just twenty or thirty
million dollars and the exchange of
financial intelligence you know like the
setting of the Office of terrorism
finance and intelligence within Treasury
is one sign of that how far has that
change in strategy been effective in in
combating terrorist financing secondly
to what extent did your efforts to
control the financing of terrorism
tackle the non banking channels as well
as the banking channels and thirdly how
far has the USA PATRIOT Act title three
being successful in in combating the
financing of terrorism thanks okay the
first question about freezing versus
tracing the money they were always
always a dual task and the terrorist
financing to both stop funds when it was
useful but also to follow the money to
get information you're exactly right
over time it's moved more in the
direction of tracing in financial
intelligence and the whole Swift
operation which was unfortunately made
public last summer was of that variety
the but on the other hand the freezing
and the sanctions is still there and in
fact the action against Banco Delta Asia
in Macau the bank that had been doing
money laundering and counterfeit bill
distribution from North Korea that was
the saying that was a direct sanction
type of thing so that was like a
freezing if you like and some of the
recent things with respect to Iran the
UN Security Council resolution right
before the holidays December 23rd I
guess that was that had freezing type
actions in it so those are still there
and they're important too and the dollar
magnitudes are not the best way to
measure non banking institutions or
informal remittance systems is a huge
issue and you have to go after those the
hawala dealers
nc transfers the cash couriers it's a
big topic and it's an area where more
work certainly needs to be done and
overall effectiveness
I'd say is very positive it's hard to
convey that with measures of numbers
unfortunately you're right 137 million
in this scheme of things is not large at
all but you have to try to find examples
where something didn't happen that might
have happened more generally I find and
reporting on these things so many things
that I think are good because they
didn't happen and no one understands
those you know it's like the like I
always say geez we have another
financial crisis in 2002 and there's no
recession ending in the world anywhere
in the world that's a big deal to me
but you know something that didn't
happen is not something that people will
focus on so it's a similar thing here go
ahead and please I'm curious if this
isn't classified to too deeply what
exactly is the process for determining
of what money is supporting the
terrorists and how our rogue states or
people you are at war with and
determining where those are going in the
banking system I assume there's a
feedback loop that the terrorists find
funds cut off and then they get better
at going deeper underground to find ways
to evade that is that a subject you know
it's a very is this requires a lot of
interagency work to do this because you
have the intelligence agencies getting
information you have the Treasury
working on the freezing you have state
Department with the certainly diplomatic
issues that will come into play if it's
a foreign entity we're talking about
freezing so it requires an enormous
amount of coordination and early on
when I saw this happening it was sort of
ad hoc but since then and maybe fire
could add something here since then it's
become more formal in terms of the
process it's not to say there aren't
mistakes this is not evidence that
beyond a shadow of a doubt type evidence
so there can be errors but it seems to
me it's it's done reasonably well and
there's a there's an auditing system
there was an auditing system in the case
of the Swift for example so I think that
it's a good process the process is
straightforward the particular cases of
course if there's an intelligence issues
related to sources or methods of course
that's qualified classify sir Krishna
grew have financial times several of the
panelists spoke today about the
intersection of national security in
international finance and economics how
essentially these are now integrated
agendas and I wanted to invite John and
fire both to talk about this in the
context of proliferation activities and
obviously in some extent the agenda is
broadened out from the immediate
al-qaida related staff post 9/11 to look
at North Korea Banco Delta Asia John
spoke about and today Stuart Levey was
talking about further actions to be
taken against an Iranian entity how
effective do you think international
us-led financial sanctions can be as a
counter proliferation strategy I think
it can be quite effective it's it's
really just beginning remember it was
just a little over a year ago that the
section 311 which was the technical way
that the Banco Delta Asia was approached
was implemented but that judging from
the reaction in North Korea and another
evidence it obviously very significant
the magnitudes of amount free of frozen
are still small I think is 23 or 24
million dollars but that Bank is
basically out of business and it would
simply by notification in the Federal
Register that this action was going to
take place and you've heard an awful lot
from
in government publicly about it so it's
definitely something that can make a
difference in the case of arm around
there's a lot more of coordination is
needed internationally to make that work
also in North Korea you have to Chinese
have to be involved one they have become
more involved in the activity I think
one advantages I see it you know after
being away for a while is it seems to me
compared to sort of traditional
sanctions the financial thing can be
more targeted and does not have
collateral damage trade sanctions have
all sorts of thing can have all sorts of
negative effects general kinds of
economic sanctions can have collateral
damage it seems to me that these actions
can be targeted more in a surgical way
to the entities that are doing the bad
things and I think that's an advantage
but we're still learning about it and
and people are learning more about its
impact but I think it's significant one
thing I would add is a number of these
sanctions measures are aimed at specific
wrongs that are taking place and so
they're aimed at dealing with a
particular or or act that's being taken
by a particular financial institution
whether there's money laundering or
counterfeiting or whatever it happens to
be and so it's important to remember
that when you look at each of these sort
of individual financial sanctions under
three into the 311 process for example
they're aimed at a particular act
they're not the strategy itself there's
a broader strategy that the
administration has it's being
implemented with this obviously feeding
into with a 311 a case for example you
know feeding into it in very obvious
ways but it's not it shouldn't be
misunderstood as being the entire
strategy
is here I'll go ahead we'll start back
there and then we'll come up here places
we see from the Commission embassy I'd
like to ask this question please the
third-world countries have relied up to
a large extent on the American
assistance ever since their independence
movement in the late 60s now this is the
first time that Americans embark on this
huge world effort in Iraq and
Afghanistan
what message can be sent to these
countries to say that you can be
reassured as to the American assistance
program even though these wars have not
finished yet I'm not sure I fully
understand the question but let me try
with this answer the issue is more the
sustainability of the support and why
you know why won't it stop this time
like people perceive it as having
stopped in the past with respect to
Afghanistan it seems to me that this was
a real concern of the administration
that the enthusiasm could wane very
quickly and so a lot of effort was put
in place to prevent that from happening
I think the NSC and for you are Steve
Hadley and condi rice deserve a lot of
credit for this for setting up a
separate basically for a while is
another weekly meeting that you would
have just on Afghanistan regardless we'd
meet every Wednesday or Thursday
whatever it was and have focus on
keeping that momentum up so it was
certainly I felt that I think actually
for my own personal views being that
there at 9/11 starting the first
fundraising knowing all the Iraqi
officials going to the country made me
more committed to not letting it slide
and of course we had major other
distract other things to think about so
it was very hard but I think there at
least since I was there it was a very
explicit effort to keep up the effort
and to convince people that it was
important
um name is chinnough to be a Beulah and
it's going to act the panel regarding
the recent translation of depth but
developed countries especially in Africa
and I wanted to ask what progress has
been made with this country's since
after the death translation and how do
you plan to hold most of this government
accountable to the depth translation in
order to maintain economic development
productivity productivity and efficiency
I just do very quickly because I think
Ulster has lots of more information
about this the purpose of the hundred
percent debt cancellation is IBEW to
originally wishes to stop this lending
forgive mentality where you'd be lending
in my sense is you alone to be going out
and literally two years later we'd be if
you come into the Treasury saying we
need to do some adjustment of this loan
and it because it went on top of a bunch
of other loans so it just created the
worst incentives you can imagine so one
of our principles was don't loan when
there's a high probability that you're
going to be forgive it screws up the
whole system so that in itself seems to
me from accountability amazing results
important to get fixed now on top of
that people have always associated debt
reduction with certain conditions you
have to fulfill to get it you know they
in the it makes sense you know you get a
little extra leverage get countries to
do something but I would say that was
not the main focus of understand it's
important to do is all where we get
leverage but maybe I'll stir can refer
to that aspect of it since I woke up
this morning not expecting to be here I
must admit I'm less than fully briefed
on on this issue but but what I do know
is that a number of of African countries
have have completed the the the the debt
the debt reduction program under
typically heavily indebted poor
countries program and and that and that
this is not just a wholesale just right
off of debt I mean been a big concern is
that the countries don't then
immediately take on more debt or use the
the resources for
but wasteful so is a wasteful for
purposes so so consequently there is a
program that involves the IMF the
country's the World Bank where they were
they sit down and and agree on a on a
coherent program for doing this I might
add that Afghanistan is one program at
one country that's entering such a
program now with the with the IMF and
and with us and this is really related
to the Soviet era debt of something like
ten billion dollars and there's a
century a program for writing all of
this off over a period of about eighteen
months thank you
certainly you want it he had a question
right here particle taken I was in the
government including the Treasury
Department over a number of years I I
wonder if you can estimate we haven't
mentioned the word opium production or
oil revenues what what are the
proportions of terrorist finance that
are derived from those kinds of sources
in countries that you you know are
familiar with and is there any way
indirectly of attacking that aspect of
the problem I have no idea what the
fraction is is huge amounts of money on
the oil it just obviously it's got to be
a teeny fraction but the magnitudes are
so big a teeny fraction is huge
magnitudes but with respect to the opium
is obviously a huge amount of revenue in
Afghanistan and I'm sure it's a it's a
source of funding how to combat it do
less of it they take care of it but give
alternative crops one which one of the
things that we first learned by going
there and talking to convinced Ishmael
Khan to give more funds to the center he
took me to meet lots of people and they
said I used promised us funds for
alternative crops where is the money
and so that was even way back in 2002 it
was it was an issue but it is a problem
I don't have any particular suggestions
or estimates for you right now you want
to you want to say something yeah I
think in the last and the last year or
so there's been this concern
about the resurgence of the Taliban in
the South of Afghanistan and Helmand
province which is one of the most
conflict affected ones within a 30
kilometre radius of of the capital of
Helmand 60 percent of Afghanistan's
opium poppy is growing and the people
who are dealing more directly with the
insurgency tell me that opium poppy is
heroin if you like it is one of the
major source of financing of the
insurgency in the south but to deal with
the problem of them narcotics and
afghanistan is enormous problem in
effect a few weeks ago we released a
report on this on the subject because
the alternative crops the alternative
livelihoods simply requires the
acceleration of rural development across
the whole of of afghanistan poppy is a
crop which will grow anywhere in the
country so if it's suppressed in one
area it can pop up somewhere else unless
measures are taken to to prevent that
my name is andrei sitov I'm with tests
that I should use agency I want to ask
you a question on Russia sir you
describe yourself as a financial warrior
some people in russia wonder water
actually is now for the united states an
ally a partner or maybe something else
so in your experience so there should be
more of a part of a solution or more a
part of a problem in your effort thank
you and maybe an episode that sticks in
your mind and maybe is in the book I
haven't read the book yet that deals
with Russian thank you actually I
thought the terminology is not
necessarily it's meant to be a broader
sense of people out there trying to do
good broadly speaking and part of the
good is what we're just talking about
combating terror is financing but also
part of the good is helping make the
world more accountable so it can be used
more effectively and working with them
and part of the good is training finance
ministers and central bank so this is a
broader sense than just the alternative
to weapons if you like is having
financial sanctions it's meant to be
much much broader than that and I think
of it I mean I my orientation as an
economist a finance person is that
there's an enormous benefits from
engaging and from trade and from
integration in the world economy and so
that actually should be a very you know
high-priority
opening markets and encouraging economic
freedom one of the things that I did
many things that did not have time to or
pages if you like to include is is this
effort to include sort of economic
freedom as part of the general promotion
of freedom around the world there's much
emphasis on democracy and political
freedom but I think we need to have more
emphasis on the economic freedom side of
it and there are some innocent
for example the Millennium Challenge
account is an example of trying to
promote economic freedom along with
political freedom the effort to engage
with Middle East North Africa the
broader Middle East North Africa
initiative it is an effort to bring the
economic freedom along with the
political freedom so it seems to me
that's an important part of the role of
the financial warriors is this economic
but I would I would sometimes be said oh
there's John Taylor again talking about
economic side of our argument the
economic freedom and whatnot you got to
get for example I'd always say you got
to get a industrial park set up in Kabul
so we can have businesses going and so
you need to have people like that saying
economics is important to the complex's
impact in practical reality the economic
freedoms were mostly used in the
experience of my country by the bad guys
the economic freedoms of the world meant
that there were offshore zones tax
havens and the like
the criminals were the first to use the
freedoms they took the money out of the
country they hid the money they did
everything in their own interest not in
not in the interest of the country so
there is a caveat I think - to that and
and in a way we could say that that was
a system that existed
because of the developed countries
developed democratic countries tolerated
that system that was taken advantage of
so my question here yeah my question
here is what what can be done and should
be done by a country like Russia that is
interest for instance in not only in
tracing the money but in restitution of
the money I'm sure a lot of other
countries in the world share this
problem with me in Africa in Asia
anywhere what can you do to help Thanks
thanks for your question well you not
only need of economic freedom you have
rules and a rule of law to prevent as
much as you can this kind of activity I
would say to me my
my knowledge of history here is the
economic freedom entrepreneurs creating
wealth is the history and the bad guys
if you like the exploiters are in the
minority here traditions generally
speaking of course there are certain
problems with enforcement of the law and
it's particularly a problem in Russia
right now so it's one of the problems I
think now is with the high oil prices an
incredible amount of revenue flowing in
there's less pressure to provide for
that economic freedom and the rules and
regulations that prevent abuse but the
the efforts to use the financial system
to prevent abuse is certainly very much
part of something that will deal with
the problems that you're mentioning a
tetraman from the Petersons it's very
national economic it's not this may not
be a question that you can Jonathan
actually some of the folly was after you
left barrio you mean I want to talk
about but but to go back to this
question of North Korea and I can't
remember the name of the bank of Macau I
there is a current I as someone who has
been in a lot of the post 9/11
environment something somewhat similar
they identify with some of the problems
that you guys face but make put it that
way and there is you on the question of
the of the freezing of the accounts in
that bank that this was the Treasury
Department acting on its own which
strikes me as as someone who's been
there as - I mean sure sure agencies
that go off may go off from time to time
on their own to some degree but but
important issues like that more often
than not
whatever administration I reasonably run
administration if I may put it that way
that would not be the case but there
certainly is that even today you see
columnist surround around the town in
the world saying this is the Treasury
acting on its own without any I mean
could you comment I mean I think you
pleasantly far er when you're talking
about the 311 process you said that well
I guess what I'm asking maybe extent
right sir our price say yes and indeed
you know these kinds work these things
are part of an overall integrated
strategy you said and you said almost
that but I would I would be useful it
seems to me she says the reporters in
the room if you if you could confirm
that good deny if I suspected you
confirm it can be very brief the that
happened particularly happened after I
left so I can't speak specifically to
that action but we did this as far was
saying this is an integrated process
these days that would a huge foreign
policy a question it would be beyond
belief if it was done without
information throughout the
administration I'm not going to answer
that question directly I think it's the
government the administration to answer
it but it's I think I shared what John
said I mean there are areas sort of
policy areas that are sort of lesser
focus that maybe an agency can run off
and do without notice from anybody else
but particularly the broader issue of
non-proliferation the broader war on
terror or the anti-terrorism initiative
there's extraordinary amounts of
collaboration of cooperation among the
agencies and big decisions are made in a
in a collaborative way so let's leave it
at that send it back please Kevin hall
at McClatchy Newspapers I want to
abusive mr. Taylor's presence to ask to
current events questions one by today to
the announcement by Treasury going after
another state on it Iranian bank and
wanted to get your sense of to what
degree do you think Iran right now is
isolated financially how successful has
the administration been in financially
shutting down avenues of finance and
then this motor in that was one yeah and
the other question is a more convention
I mean you put your more conventional
economists had on in terms of the
inverted yield curve back in the news
again what should it mean I love to do
inverted yield curves and
non-proliferation the same question
okay maybe the second solution first the
inverted yield curve to me simply
reflects the fact that there's some
tightening at the Fed to prevent
inflation from picking up and markets
believe that's eventually going to work
so you got a longer rate that's below
the short rate and the longer rates
would pick up if they there's risks and
inflation begin to rise later which of
course there's some risk and then
they're going to be will be a flattening
of the curve but it does not signal
recession by any means to me I don't
quite sure I understand all your
questions about Iran there I think the
main thing is so far there's these
broader sanctions like in UN Security
Council resolution which by the way have
a lot of exceptions and so that's why I
think they need to be monitored and
looked at very carefully if you look
there's a comparison after 9/11 there
was also unique United Nations Security
Council resolution for al-qaeda but in
the US and Treasury in particular there
was a specific monitoring group that was
set up we called the war room to follow
countries compliances with a resolution
so my sense now this is just a thought
or recommendation I think it needs to be
more support of this kind of activity in
one way is to do a better monitoring
system than the UN may do on their own
by watching over the compliance of these
Iranian sanctions kind of danced around
it more directly the question was there
seems to be an increasing amount of kind
of self policing or self self-regulation
and particularly the European banks and
just trying to get a sense from your
perspective how successful the broader
push on these individual actions it
seems less important than getting
particularly Europeans to stop financing
oil projects and things so this would be
for example UBS
saying they're not going to deal with
certain institutions I think that's
progress but I don't know to what extent
that's how significant it is I just do
not know the details about that I know
those particular cases that's obviously
promising but I don't know how pervasive
it is sorry I'm curious to know what if
any in your experiences private sector
played whether they were in the banking
industry or large multinational
corporations in helping to either
implement these policies in the post
9/11 world you know the world of private
sector is to me essential I mean I
basically made a point of getting views
from the private sector when it's
actually one of the difficult things to
do for a person that had my position
because you know you can affect the
private sector by doing things you know
of debt cancellation or whatever so you
want to get information the same time
not convey information obviously want to
convey information about your policies
more generally but I think the private
sectors participation was you guys I see
Adam lyric in front of me here the
private sector had a huge role in
Argentina's debt are right down and
negotiation and a lot of that it's like
actually a promising thing that they
basically set up a process to to
represent hundreds of thousands of
holders of Argentine bonds that's
something that I think is very important
in the case of the terrorist financing
they had private sector of course has to
implement these rules and regulations no
your customer etc so their participation
is important here I think the we have to
those in the public sector have to be
sure that the requirements are not
overly difficult or costly that is too
costly given the benefits and so I think
there needs to be more conveying of the
benefits to the private sector
institutions of this intelligence that
we're getting by their reporting but
generally speaking I think there's this
especially in the financial markets the
need for a lot of coordination or
cooperation with the private sector
currency markets for sure you know you
have to have their participation in what
you're doing so I attended emphasized a
lot private sector and how we would
cooperate should cooperate with the
private sector yes sir in the back
thank you I'm not Randy Henning at the
Peterson Institute and today one of the
most other parts of the book John that
most discussion of exchange rate and I
wanted to ask you or invite you to
elaborate a little bit on your formation
of the g3 group about the company that
raises
Oh
confusion okay so briefly the g3 is a
term that I used in the book to refer to
a series of collaborations between the
United States Europe and Japan on
currency markets and the discussions
were at my level and we began in 2003
related to what I call the great
Japanese intervention and related to the
efforts to move China off of their Pig
so it is I think it's these are huge
countries important currencies and so
that dialogue is important much of it is
is essentially exchanged information of
an irregularity of communication one of
the things that we noticed there was a
glitch at the beginning is the
responsibilities for currency in the in
Europe have changed this is part of the
answer to your question
traditionally currency markets are
responsibility of the Finance Ministry's
rather than central bank's so in the
United States the Treasury has the
dollar that that has interest rate and
the Bank of Japan has their interest
rate whatever it is and the currency
market is a moth in Europe it's become
more complicated because with the
formation of the European Central Bank
they obviously have responsibility for
the interest rate but then who has
responsibility for the exchange rate
there's no not a natural entity of
Finance Ministry's there's a Euro group
but but and so in what happened
eventually as the g3 became a sort of a
g3 prime because the central bank
european central bank had to participate
in those discussions so it was very
beneficial and it's a way to again keep
on top of things know who you're dealing
with there if there's a crisis or if
there's an intervention of some kind or
concern about the currencies moving too
far so I thought it was very very
valuable I don't really see at this
point the advantages of having it
ministerial
if you like as long as of course the
Minister should be informed about what's
going on but I don't see a ministerial
dialog is too particularly fruitful we
have time for one last question
yes sir where's the mic all right thank
you hi I'm David Nelson a bureaucratic
question for you a structural issue you
talk about the sort of carrot side and
the stick side of the of what you are
doing the carrots being you know the
technical assistance the the building
structures the loans the debt
forgiveness etc and on the stick side
the work against terrorist finance the
the sanctions type of issues since
you've left they those functions have
been bifurcated at Treasury they as
they've got an undersecretary handling
the terrorists finance side and a
different job handling the international
affairs side I guess one could say that
that's because it takes 200 secretaries
to do the work that you did a loan
before but maybe you could provide a
little more insight into the sort of
pros and cons of bifurcating those those
pieces of our international work thank
you the bifurcation is not quite as
extreme as you put because you used to
be under secretary for enforcement
before the undersecretary for terrorist
finance and intelligence so in some
sense the creation of Homeland Security
which took Secret Service customs Bureau
of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms out of
the Treasury meant that the secretary
enforcement had a much different role
and so for that reason the terrorism
financial intelligence position was
created okay having said all that it
seems to me that it is useful to have
this different person doing that it is
it is a tremendous amount in and Stuart
levees very busy and doing terrific work
as is as is Tim Adams they both got
their hands full so I think it's fine
but I do think that there is a need to
have both sides way and I think for
example when there is a sanction or a
targeting of a bank or a freezing it
seems to me it's always important to
mention that capital u.s. capital
markets remain open and we're positive
about trade so you don't sort of get
into the mentality of stopping rather
than encouraged
all the time so I think that's an
important thing to address but to tooth
under secretaries make sense to me thank
you very much John I'd like to thank you
for providing providing this time we
booked on a profoundly important topic
and I'd like to thank Alastair McKechnie
and fire sure Zod